según las cifras de associated press en
arizona ya con un 97 por ciento de los
votos contados yo bailé le lleva una
ventaja a donald trump de cerca de 30
mil votos en nevada con un 93 por ciento
de otros contados la ventaja es de cerca
de 22 mil votos en pensilvania con el
96% de votos contados la ventaja ya
crece a 28 mil votos y en georgia con el
99 por ciento de los votos contados y
teniendo en cuenta que se va a ser un
reconteo la ventaja de bailén ya es de
cerca de 7.000 votos hay que resaltar
que hoy
valentina en arizona a las 11 de la
mañana hora del este de eeuu habrá una
nueva actualización de los votos sobre
todo de los votos en el condado de
maricopa donde está phoenix y lo que
dicen las autoridades
electorales de ese estado es que para
entonces sabremos casi la totalidad de
los votos de ese estado quiero resaltar
lo que de ganar byd en arizona sería la
primera vez que ganaría ese estado en 24
años y de ganar georgia
y un demócrata gane ese estado en más de
28 años en cuanto a trump y el discurso
de baile en trompa reaccionado en sus
redes sociales diciendo que pues de
forma milagrosa empezó a perder estos
estados que le acabo de mencionar pero
que espera que después de las batallas
legales que él pues está empezando a ver
pues a imponer y tratar de demandar
estas autoridades electorales la ventaja
sea para el partido demócrata
republicano y para su campaña a la
presidencia